[Music]
that bonnet is a [ __ ]
reading some podcast Ville the church
what's happened now is brought to you by
zip recruit listen it's a new year right
hiring is challenging there's a lot of
Momo's out there but there's one place
you could go we're hiring is simple fast
and smart you ready
zip recruit it it's we're growing
businesses connect to qualified
candidates how do I know his little
story co-founder Gretchen Greg Deana
codable co-founder Gretchen a blur
experience how challenging hiring was
after unsuccessfully searching for a new
game artist to grow with her education
tech company but then she switched to
zip recruiter and saw an immediate
difference in you to sign up for free
right now at zip recruited comm slash
Church with results like that it's no
wonder four out of five employers who
post on zip recruiter get a quality
candidate within the first day one day
no looking through resumes cuz time is
money you know that you're a business
man why am I telling you this
see why it's difficult is effective for
all businesses of all sizes whether you
got a shoe store or a supermarket or a
cartel zip recruiter is gonna help you
out try super cool it for free and
exclusive web address zip recruited
dot-com / Church that zip recruiter Doc
Tom slash shirts zip recruiter a better
way to hire any way today and the church
is my main man Cory and Chad the [ __ ]
crash brothers why they're here honoring
our brothers fallen brothers birthday
how long how old we we would have been
throughout it would been forty eight
forty [ __ ] eight today yep that's a
big 48 yeah that's a big four to forty
eight at 484 anyone good to see you guys
good to see check in with you thank you
for always checking in with me thank you
for letting me know what you
oh yeah we like checking in with you
from the road it's always fun to get
inspirational quotes from coca when
we're out on the road oh you have to
it's funny how years ago I went on Maya
I will not already shown I told the
story that really taught me who I was it
was about my mother her dying and she
had a friend and the friend made a
promise I thought the thing and she
stuck to it and you know there were 200
people my mom's waked he said if you
ever need anything call and yeah
they changed the number but this person
in you and it really taught me when
somebody has a friend there even your
friend after death and in this case with
all of my Dubrow he gave away and all
the [ __ ] friends he had at least
they were you two guys set up I don't
know who raised you this way but they
did a good job because you still all
look to his old legacy I see little
quotes from time to time emissions [ __ ]
like yeah we just want to you know keep
Ralphie's name out there he was a good
man to us and somebody that was
inspirational to us that did things for
us that not many people really did
stepped up and I'm not just talking
comedy as a man as a friend and we spend
many hours on that bus just talking
heart-to-heart laughing and talking [ __ ]
and and he just means a lot you know
it's his birthday today February 17th he
would have been 48 and [ __ ] who knows
what he'd be talking about in his comedy
right now with all this censorship and
all this people with salty [ __ ] all
you know no imagine will he beat right
now hotel bar yes he used to [ __ ] up a
hotel bar oh yeah I told you Caroline's
one time I got there at 2:00 he checked
in at 12:00 he was on his second bar not
like downstairs Oh many things we've
seen yeah them's kid cats peanut brittle
whatever the [ __ ] was in there cheese
crackers he called for another bat he's
like I'm done my friends were here
nobody was here by yourself
you [ __ ] [ __ ] we loved it when
we were on the road with him and he'd
get those sweets but he'd rather stay on
the bus sometimes and we take over his
suite and we'd order room service and
put on a row
answer the door and pretend we're Ralphy
and sign sign his name and order all
kinds of [ __ ] get naked in his jacuzzi
and send him pictures of us naked in his
[ __ ] jacuzzi just talking [ __ ] to him
tell him to get off his [ __ ] bus and
get his lazy ass in here and let's party
and because you know the last couple
years he'd hibernate on that bus he
loved that bus just stay on that bus you
miss them guys yeah yeah sometimes we'll
hear certain songs and different things
and it makes us laugh or whenever we're
listening to Pandora or serious and we
hear Ralphie's bits come on it always
makes us laugh we always turn down and
tell everyone to shut the [ __ ] up in the
car so we can listen to his bit you know
and just to hear it's voice that's crazy
now just me being me I haven't accepted
his death yet yeah to me he's still on
the road you know when it hits me you
guys don't know and I'm gonna follow you
guys a lot sometimes it's weird
I [ __ ] scroll I open up the phone to
call somebody and it opens up to Ralph I
still have my [ __ ] heart stops and
especially if it happens on a Saturday
morning mm-hmm because that's when you
guys watakhayzoo the wind out of me you
know and it's really weird the process
of grieving like it doesn't matter
whether it's Ralph or anybody else the
process of grieving is such a small one
you know and I gotta tell you this few
people who still talk to me about
Ralphie it's you guys and George yet
again in the car with George and we're
driving around New York don't pop out
one time Ralphie took me in there we ate
tiny 22 pounds of lobster tail yeah I
believe and it's weird how you see
people that I know for a fact profited
from Ralphie out here and I'll see them
waiting for him to say something to me
about Ralphie and they won't mention it
it's like Ralph he was just a person who
went through life not to us yeah
to us he meant something a lot more it's
so weird how listen let's face it I'm
gonna be this was last week I was in
Tempe I want to thank the Tempe improv
having me the soul nachos
Chelsea Skidmore hoping for me as she
did a great job she's saying you know I
need a girl in front of me because
so many [ __ ] couples come sure so
many women buy tickets for their
boyfriends they don't want to say me
he'll like just wanna appease the
boyfriend and now they gotta hear all
this [ __ ] yeah so I try to I always do
better with a girl whenever I have a
woman in front of me the [ __ ] crowd
goes crazy and where we feel the same
way it's really weird it's it's a weird
combination to have but it was great but
I thought about how this week was my
birthday but guess what like did like my
mother died my birthday changed your
birthday has an Asterix - it's like
Christmas and Thanksgiving sure all the
holidays now it has another asterisk and
it's Ralphy like just as I was getting
excited about it being my birthday I
also dreaded Monday cuz it was his
birthday yeah I was gonna feel you know
yeah I'm happy that you guys could just
drive up and just [ __ ] [ __ ] tell
us mister oh yeah laughs and I didn't he
told me when he fell asleep at the
restaurant
and then he woke up with his food with
cold and he ordered more food yeah
[ __ ] Tony Roma's before a show he
fell asleep and tucked his napkin in
that's the best part for the visual he
typed his napkin into his [ __ ] shirt
for 30 [ __ ] minutes add a napkin was
like a baby then yeah no matter how big
the napkin was always having it was like
a baby napkin like on his [ __ ] like a
bar napkin cuz he was that big yeah
[ __ ] snoring at the table head snaps
back you ain't so that'd be fine
why is this [ __ ] keep bringing me cold
ribs talking about they've been sitting
there for 30 minutes you let me sleep
who the [ __ ] leaves at Tony Roma's or
wherever the Red Lobster wherever the
[ __ ] we I still go back to that night
with you know it's it's weird how he's
been gone for two years yeah away or
whatever the [ __ ] I call these in
college yeah and now sometimes you go to
a comedy club and a club oh no mention
them yeah and tell me a story whether
it's a positive or a negative Jerry
right
and then and then you wants to support
house and he gets flashbacks yeah
sometimes he gets flashbacks ain't puts
back
it doesn't episode would [ __ ] waste
nuts getting flashbacks and he puts
together how [ __ ] actually became a
snitch yeah like now I go flashbacks of
conversations we had and now I see why
we had that conversation yeah now I see
why he said those words to me mmm now I
go back oh [ __ ]
that's what he was talking about you
know and I'm putting these pieces
together that's so weird out I always
enjoyed the broke Ralphie at the end of
the day broke Ralphie was 20 times
happier than yeah it's Ralph's a great a
great it's [ __ ] so sad that you know
to tell people that all your life you
work you know you strive to be this rich
person like everybody wants a boat and
[ __ ] and you know rims and to get
your dick sucked but if you knew him
like for me he was happier when he was
in that [ __ ] apartment headlining
killing wrongs killing killing loans and
people were not expecting it selling
merch early on you know way before last
comics yeah you know and I still
remember Jamie Moore coming into his
life and Jay being positive for all the
things Jay is Jay's a good guy yes bit
them made a musashi 't producer of a
show jay was hot yeah Jay was hot yeah
Jay [ __ ] pulled Ralphie up you know
that he created last comic with the
black guy Walter yeah where the [ __ ] is
Waldo I think he's we're gonna name him
last time I saw man I created that
[ __ ] show and [ __ ] with yep
with Jeff Wood
what's his name Ralphie in there yep
yeah that that show did a lot for Ralph
and yeah broke Ralph's more money more
problems he would say to when he was
collecting these checks he's all boys
enjoy these times you're making good
money but more money comes more problems
and staying on the road when you're
like he was staying on the road all
kinds of problems happen at home you
know when you're not there to check in
with your family and life and calling in
that's before FaceTime and check you
know he wasn't FaceTime and anybody else
he was just calling in whenever he woke
up you know and that that was the one
thing I took away his comedy career
listen ayat I studied Mitch
I studied Stan oh yeah well I studied
Bobby Slayton I studied a Wendy Liebman
when you're a comic you look at these
headliners when you're a feature and you
study them and you get to the point of
what makes them special and you try to
emulate it see if it works for you for
me it was like Richard Jeni and seeing
Paul Mooney
for a while there Rogan was [ __ ] on
fire 20 years ago I mean his material
was so out there there was so many
people that I learned from Ralphie was
one of those guys I've learned more of
life offstage right how I should live my
life offstage you know I wish I always
crack jokes i sternum Rogan kwangmin
donate I'm going to the gym we're on the
road I'm calling you like at 10:00 in
the morning I am going through the gym
I'm like we're on the road like what
[ __ ] Jimmy you talking yeah like
after a few days going down there with
him these [ __ ] doing cleans and [ __ ]
I'm like I ride the bike like 10 minutes
that's all you got me for yeah you know
and now I see the importance of working
out sad I didn't want to work out like
[ __ ] went down to the hotel I mean I
did 30 minutes on the elliptical and
threw some weights around you know from
lousy I learned more the path of not to
take off the [ __ ] Road like you know
that was the thing Ralphie was so old
school that he knew what I knew that I
just realized this year
look these agents and all these people
once they get their hooks on you for the
road that's all the time is your fault
yeah there's no films there's no TV
projects anymore once then you talk to
them 80 times
nope they'll meet with you once a month
and don't bring all the assistants and
all the agents but they're making a big
Commission off you then when you would
be out making on TV yeah why are we
having this conversation so would you
what would you rather make $500 or
$5,000 right yeah so you know from your
world you're like man I wanted to do
more you know for a while there Ralphy
we didn't want TV yeah I did and they
were saying no you're too fat which he
[ __ ] was yeah they weren't lying to
him he didn't see it you know but he
decided to become a road comic and not
just a road comment one of the best guys
working I mean he at the bus to how this
belt the [ __ ] orange jacket you know
yeah but I didn't learn I learned little
from that it was more of how to act off
the [ __ ] stage and the one thing I
picked up from day one of his marriage
daddy I never liked [ __ ] listen as a
feature act and never liked work in a
[ __ ] Sunday waking up in Dallas I'm
not saying there's nothing wrong with
Dallas I'm just useless where it
happened to me it was Dallas right well
I roped up I got beat up all week by
rocky Laporte the same curses or
improvising or whatever I'm like what
the [ __ ] am i doing in this world right
it's 10:00 in the morning I had a city
all [ __ ] day for a seven o'clock
[ __ ] show that nobody's gonna be at
it's [ __ ] football season yeah
Sunday's are the worst yeah and it's a
free room so it's a bunch of old people
with white hair that come to the seven
o'clock show yeah you know I'm like I'm
done you know and I remember just having
a relationship with my girlfriend at the
time and going I gotta be home for
Sunday dinner just because we don't have
kids doesn't mean when I'm volved in
something yeah for sure this is the same
important to go back and [ __ ] that's
where Ralphie didn't come home he'd
[ __ ] stay on that bus eat Monday
night chose Tuesday night funny bones he
was on and even if he didn't pick up
word that's when he'd regenerate and
sleep like a [ __ ] Grizz listen let me
tell you something if I didn't have a
child and my wife worked I would
disappear for three weeks
doesn't make sense to come back yeah
yeah it really does
sometimes it really doesn't yeah it's a
three-week run you know you gonna go to
Buffalo William do all I'm back here for
three days and go all the way back if I
have a kid was married like we had a
girlfriend what are you [ __ ] kidding
me yeah I would either take her with me
or just say I'm leaving for three weeks
[ __ ] do Buffalo Sunday stay the spend
the night in Buffalo eat some wings yeah
you know relax in your hotel room
Monday morning shoot the Newark yep
spend the three days and you know the
hotel and or whatever go I don't give a
[ __ ] sleep yeah and then Thursday go to
New York pay the [ __ ] yeah if I punch
you tonight for the whole time two
blocks and Gotham yeah where do you two
shows do Sunday cuz you're gonna be on
the road anyway you might as well work
Sunday that's what I'm saying
yeah you know you get more [ __ ] bang
for your dollar and you might as well do
it Thursday show I think maybe just one
show that Wednesday right maybe one show
up in Nyack on Wednesday and then
Thursday you go to DC right you know
that that's a smart move on the train
that's a smart move for anybody
sure I can't do that move people
understand that you just can't you yeah
it's not it's work for me to come home
and do the podcast and lift some [ __ ]
weights and go to boxing and go to the
cow Bistro Insurance day and work on the
material you know for me that's what
works right but for Ralphie he was doing
these I still remember him like I'm
leaving it out we don't I gotta go to
have his own do press for next week yep
and I didn't know what the [ __ ] was
going on I'm like something's gotta be
going on because who gives a [ __ ] about
next week it's next week
but there wasn't no twin event right
there wasn't no Facebook that people
know and really podcasting wasn't his
thing no until he was a great guest he
wouldn't want to do a podcast you know
he tried his shed for a while and he's
better cast any of us running he you
wouldn't do it every week you know I
mean he would follow through with that
[ __ ] so the last couple weeks I guess
you and I
all three of us have been the object of
just like you know we're getting treated
like three guys that watch the
documentary right to learn about ralfie
man like yeah right now for people who
don't know I think it was last Saturday
I woke up 20 ml from a writer nice guy
you know now he's just doing his job
you're wrong he's trying to put an
article together for his ex-wife and you
know I think with you he twisted your
words around yeah with me I told him fax
you know that things that I had seen
over the years you know I had like I
said I'd been there when while I had a
day job right she drove a Camry you know
I've been there since day one right and
now in hindsight you looked at bits and
pieces and all i caught this I caught
that ice tournament and I never told
anybody that she was uh you know uh when
people get married to be oh like gold
digger gold digger that was a lie you
know she's there from when there was no
money yeah yeah so I give one all those
credits but I have a couple
disagreements with what happened how
things were handled after his death and
two years prior to his death right now
and all three of us know here as men
that Ralphie was no saint
yeah Ralphie had demons that were coming
back to haunt them but they were all
awoken by this horrible relationship he
had found himself in one day
yeah he was trapped if you look back at
what I saw what I see
yeah and you guys before the podcast
started told the story where you heard
her you know on the phone yeah and kill
yourself yeah they just cry and yeah
whole thing were men let's talk about
just let people it wasn't you know
Ralphie's relationship at the end of the
past couple years it wasn't
happy-go-lucky they were going through a
divorce for years years and it was back
and forth and Ralphie was a mess
emotionally physically
ya know he was losing weight but at the
same time he was gaining weight drinking
a 12-pack of Coca Cola's you know people
I think a lot of people think Oh Ralph
he's a big guy he always must ate a lot
that's not the case he would just drink
cokes and he would eat late-night and he
wouldn't do anything and he was
lethargic and that's why he gained
weight and the whole thing with Lana and
you know she's out there talking
disparaging [ __ ] on the three of us you
know and the whole thing is is she's not
innocent in this whole situation she
would say horrible things to Ralphie
horrible horrible things to Ralphie and
Ralphie said horrible things to her then
that's why we try to separate ourselves
on tour during the divorce because we
were caught in the middle and things
were getting wild and Ralphie needed
time away from the road and nobody his
management nobody was backing up Ralphie
coming off the road you know there's
probably a lot of overhead and he had to
go out and get it yeah but you know
whatever she's saying on these podcasts
isn't really you know we didn't enable
Ralphie to do anything you know Ralphie
did whatever the [ __ ] he wanted to do on
the road people understand that yeah
Ralphie was you know just I had a
thousand conversations about I'm
switching the schedule yeah I still
remember one specific conversation where
it was like one of those it's time for
you to do this yeah it's time for me to
go out there with you maybe help you
walk whatever yeah yeah let's do a
Gabriel aces type thing for openers yeah
cool let's take care of you yeah Wow he
turned me down you know because he
didn't want me to see that other side of
the road he was doing no the same way I
didn't want you to see what I was doing
prior to 2007 we just pulled on the road
yeah I do cocaine I think about the
fight was doing cocaine now I'd be on
the road of your weekend sure cuz I come
home and get it together for four days
through the podcast then Thursday night
I'd fly into a town and it better be
there at midnight yes I could sleep it
off all day Friday show sad
and it better be there Saturday so I
could sleep it off yep and do the one
show on son I mean that would be there
that I couldn't I would come home either
you know this is all we all saw this
southern kid with manners just become a
star overnight yeah and then we saw him
even climb higher [ __ ] goals and then
something happened like one day just
something switched you know and it was
sad you know I heard little things here
and there for anybody who believes this
whether you believe this is not we never
really had a conversation about those
right as much of a junkie as I am I
didn't have the heart to confront them
because I knew that I would lose him he
wasn't too confronting tight right like
even got his feelings hurt one time when
I had a conversation with Lana after
they were separated I just tried to have
a conversation with her and got back
then and he was mad at me like four or
five months he didn't speak to me that's
how sensitive Oh God he felt betrayed
did she talk to her right something
happens I said something to one or
something and you don't have to
Ralphie's death the month the two before
three maybe four months before Ralphie's
death I heard I found out from different
sources the things that was going on
during this divorce she interact is a
shion's
you know have you been accused of
something you haven't done
hmm not a nice feeling no it's not you
know and listen I've been accused of
things I haven't done but I was all that
put myself there sure was a thief and
that's it's not nice when you get
accused of something yeah right yeah I'm
not getting accused in 1995 a sexual
harassment or grabbing some girls ass
I'm like if you know anything about me
yeah you know she said grab a [ __ ] then
believer yes yes I'm gonna never build a
smack of an ass like that yeah so if I'm
gonna grab so I'm gonna grab your [ __ ]
and do two years
I'm gonna grab and grab
yeah the [ __ ] you clear up you'll have
cliff damage yeah assault two daggers
you know yeah
so it's always horrible to get accused
of things and I I saw that he was and
now I know there was a situation where
he couldn't see his kids without uh yeah
supervised visit revised visit yeah he
didn't see his kids the last couple
years he was alive no that's weird that
as a man I could tell you something now
that you know I lost my origional
daughter I have a 30 year old daughter
we don't talk and I can sit here and
tell you all the pros and cons and tell
you how the wife but I'm gonna tell you
something looking back at who the person
I was then in 1994 when I was going
through all that I wouldn't give him
permission to my wife to see let me see
the kid right I was a different human
being that I would harm the child me and
not the child or anything like that but
I was a type of person that if the drug
dealer told me at 4:00 I had to meet him
now cuz he couldn't meet me at 8:00 and
I got my kid I'm going to meet the drug
dealer I'm big enough of a man now to
tell you these things right I was that
crazy back then my god I think about
myself of my daughter now in the car and
who I was back then it's two different
stories Rafi didn't have a little bit of
a problem yeah and I would be a little
hesitant about letting kids go on his
car also
yeah hurts the stories that maybe she
fabricated them but I don't think she
did on these yeah she told me some she
was on you know as far as some of the
things she's saying are pretty accurate
and then a lot is just fabricated to to
make Ralphie look really really poor a
lot of people have come to you about
this documentary have come to us all of
us and we haven't seen it we're not
gonna see it we were on the road during
the filming of this it was never meant
to see the light of day
whatever first it was a weight loss
thing then she changed it to whatever
the [ __ ] she called it now but Ralphie
never wanted that on he didn't even want
that chick on the bus filming us he
didn't want it he told us get rid of her
and and finally he sent her home from
Boston or whatever city we were in I
think we did the Wilbur theater in
Boston
and then he sent her home and he didn't
he didn't think that thing would ever
come out you know and then after he died
all of a sudden now there's this [ __ ]
documentary but Ralph didn't want it we
were preparing for his Netflix special
that's what we were doing you know we
were reviewing his jokes every night and
getting him ready for his Netflix
special that's what it was for so
whatever it is now you know she can say
whatever she wants you know like I said
my brother and I just choose not to even
be involved you know what I mean because
Ralphie would be upset with us if we
were involved you know what I mean and
we're gonna honor him for the rest of
our lives and and he's all we care about
and she can say whatever she wants but
we didn't engage we didn't give him
anything
you know Ralphie did whatever the [ __ ]
he wanted you know you know you know we
chatting I had never done pills so we
never had that relationship with Ralphie
either you know that was something that
he did that in his privacy of his pose
of Pama potables yeah before 2007 I did
blow Ralphie didn't do was even much of
a drinker really so you know it wasn't I
don't like the allegations that we were
doing drugs with him yeah prior days to
his death the only drugs I did with
Ralphie were edibles Chiba shoes I
didn't wanna throw me under the bus for
that be my [ __ ] guest he had been
smoking reefer way before he ever met
Lana yes he had been smoking reefer that
was his way of dealing with things over
that and when they did the autopsy
whatever there was no drugs and ralphie
systems so she can say whatever you know
go on these podcasts Ralphie wasn't on
drugs he can't even smoke weed a couple
weeks before he died he wasn't even
smoking weed because he didn't feel good
and so he was staying out in Vegas at a
friend's house or whatever but Ralphie
wasn't doing anything the night before
you know whatever TMZ's that was all
[ __ ] - yeah he had bronchitis yeah
he had bronchitis and Ralph wasn't
feeling good and you know so whatever it
is but I know that me and my brother did
not enable him to do anything
nobody enables yeah you know listen if
anybody knows any stand-up comics
stand-up comics wiring we became
stand-up comics because the wiring is
that way something is short there's a
short somewhere in that [ __ ]
circuitry so one of the shorts is that
eight out of ten comma should have is I
don't know how to say this without sign
you know something rude but it's no
respect for authority that was
regardless into comedy first of that
there was that boss that broke our balls
hmm don't the day we wanted to be our
own boss we were looking to throw of our
own destiny so because of that it's a
strength and a weakness that most
comedians have that we're gonna do when
I'm gonna [ __ ] it is all gonna do it and
we're gonna do it you know and that's
just the way life is
and then we wait for the consequences
and the last two years we've seen this
for comics live push the barriers yep
and didn't even know they were pushing
the barriers some did some didn't and
the result has been you know whatever
you want to call it from society you
know Brian Ashwin door a slight
punishment or as I call it a louis c.k
timeout right right you know Lucy case
on a weekend right but there's some
people want the house going he's
terrible he took his dick out yeah if he
did it was [ __ ] 15 years ago yeah all
right we're gonna it was 93 wasn't it
yeah so you still angry Louis meanwhile
losing them des Moines Iowa selling out
13 shows the funny bone in a row yeah
but you people in New York I'm [ __ ]
still pissed at him when he walks into
the Comedy Cellar yeah you know it's
just a [ __ ] weird thing with Ralphie
though it was like with this whole
newspaper thing first of all this the
film obviously whenever people try to
talk to me about the film every other
day mhm
I stir I get little Facebook messages
that they got it and they feel really
bad or whatever but the most message I
get is that it turns into her oh like it
turns into her which is what she's still
doing here I never wanted anything wrong
for long
wanted to wish her any harm yeah I see
he was my friend
okay before anything he was my friend I
saw how the last two years of his life
will lived what do you want me to do be
your friend after I saw this
you know the rape allegation yeah do you
know the rape allegation is guys do you
have any idea what a rape allegation I
mean we never had it against us but we
know what any idea what rape allegation
it's bad do you have any idea what a
rape allegation is you know how bad
kidnapping was when I got arrested for
kidnapping dog they were looking at me
like hours of [ __ ] Marcia and I think
right next to kidnap me kidnapping is
the cousin to rape Yeah right you know
it's like the cousin the dirty cousin to
rape yeah they treat you like that right
so until I lost that kidnapping I could
take a breath once they started talking
about second-degree burglary accessory
to a family well I didn't realize how
seriously kidnapped them what hmm they
take kidnapping [ __ ] serious and they
give you time and you know what happens
when you get on the prisoners whatever
but rape I know this kid man I know this
kid 23 years and guess what I got locked
up and there was a rapist in the thing
and they do have a different smell when
you're around a rapist they have a
different stall time is funny there was
a comedian where I looked at years ago
and said I could see this guy raping
somebody and I just found out two
weekends ago they did try to rape
somebody [ __ ] I never judged him I never
told nobody he was a raping [ __ ]
but look lady great yeah I find out now
two years later he did tried to rape
somebody years ago on a tour you know on
some [ __ ] tour it's not Brad Williams
I'm not talking about for you people
think we put Brad alone we're working
with them next weekend yeah bleep for
Brad alone some chick is drunk he goes
you [ __ ] a [ __ ] you don't know it
shame on you
yeah it's like the Dodge is one of the
trophy now go [ __ ] yourself yeah they
cheated on you you dumb white
[ __ ] if you weren't paying
attention in 2020 yeah come on trust
nobody
yeah I pet a cat I look at his eyes
right now you feed a pigeon you look he
died on that evil dirty virus-infected
Corona pigeon yeah listen truth no it's
a [ __ ] truth so yeah you know shame
on [ __ ] you but that rape allegation
yeah I can't get over that I'm done I
know I've been there I've know nobody's
ever accused me of rape god forbid yeah
but I've been there when somebody's
accused me of something I haven't done
but I know what his little when he told
me about the rape I saw the pain in his
eyes so I broke his heart and that's it
for me that was it that's he died I knew
I never had the same nothing to her that
ever again mixed in with child custody
the years long divorce going from being
on the road toward getting a residency
in Vegas just so he could be in one spot
you know so he so he could see his kids
that's why he took the residency at
Harris so he could be closer to his kids
he wanted to see him you know any missed
them and and we get it I'm not telling
you we're not telling he was the
greatest dad
we're not telling you that but while we
are saying is he loved him he loved his
kids a lot of kids but with all his
heart and he just wanted to see him and
I understand if she wanted him die again
another situation which one he uses
divorce
we both are now who is the one that had
the problem with the custody I thought
it was a battle in there I wanted how
bad do you feel me and you I just got
over it and it happened to me in 1995
wait here is it yeah 20 25 years of pain
it took me maybe till 2010 to get over
the he walked down the aisle with
somebody you marry him and all of a
sudden you have a child two kids and all
of a sudden one day you decide you don't
want to be with that person anymore
and there's two options they could be
the nice option way I don't want to be
with you either
let's work let's work through it then
there's the option of going a war with
somebody and unless you've been through
it please don't [ __ ] judge it yeah
because I I treat divorced men
differently I know what they've been so
I even asked me father-in-law we have
thank God my ex-wife got a boyfriend
yeah I got my girlfriend we mingle we
keep the kids you know that's always a
great thing when you have a evil divorce
I don't wish to hurt anybody
that's why Toby but before you get
married think twice during three times I
want you to see her other side and look
at her and what could she want to see
what is she capable of [ __ ] doing hmm
you know when you break up with a woman
that's got a child her first difference
is you're not gonna see your kid yeah or
you left me for a second Terry wall
you're not gonna see your kid right
that's ten number one defense and I feel
bad there's some women the nighttime um
let percentages may be wrong with my
judgment call may be wrong but for the
most part there's a lot of women that
that's their first thing to go for yeah
and you know what that's what it becomes
a [ __ ] shame yeah yeah because you use
of a [ __ ] porn here we have a porn in
between us and the kids suffer you know
kids do something because in their
little minds they can't wrap their heads
around what's going on
yeah there's no dad's not pay enough
they're not mentally prepared yeah
they're not mentally prepared now here
was a man that loved those kids but
hated the thought of coming home yeah
he'd take the ear beatings you know and
you just home life wasn't good for Ralph
he'd rather stay on the road or we just
stay in Nashville you know we he had a
house in Nashville we would just stay
there and then we'd go back on the road
but he didn't want to come what did she
fall for the one that he thought also
she followed first most times the first
time and then and reconcile reconciled
and then he did serve her you know could
afford the ten-year anniversary they
were going to be married for ten years
he served her
and she talked him out of it whatever
and that was 2015 yeah and then and then
he went through a two-year divorce you
know he was living in Vegas they they
Hera's least on my house he's living in
this big seven six bedroom [ __ ] house
by himself just sad and we'd go see him
and visit him but yeah the last two
years of his life he was going through a
hell of a [ __ ] divorce and people
don't really think about that you know
she's you know oh you know poor Ralphie
or whatever she's doing now but she put
Ralph's life through hell the last two
years of his life you know you know it
we all talked too long you talk to him
every Saturday he just uh his last
couple years of his life man was not
happy times I could tell you that and it
was tough for him to perform he'd be an
emotional mess about the whole thing you
know and it was tough for Ralph to
perform then he got sick and he couldn't
kick that sickness and ended up you know
passing away that night or whatever so
here we are a couple years later and
people are still talking negative about
the poor big boy it's like hey let's let
them rest in peace and let's let's talk
about the good things and let's put a
rest to Lotte some noticed a club owner
or a club manager say something a story
to me about Ralphie they always follow
it up with we really loved them too
oh for sure it was a shame yeah you know
let's get this straight yeah there
wasn't a club all the way that that man
never got man back the room yeah that
man took care of the waitstaff I learned
from mother he would bring a pound of
weed for the waitstaff oh yeah $300 each
like he would line up the whole [ __ ]
staff and he'd give him couple hundred
bucks each at the holster though I mean
this was a guy that would give you the
shirt off his back and you know for some
me to write an article about somebody
based off a [ __ ] book that his
assistant [ __ ] Road yeah right that
bus some [ __ ] [ __ ] and now though the
words of wanna Turner who is an angry
woman she got angry I mean things have
not worked out and heard that I wrote
her an email
yeah I wrote her an email wrapped around
four he died and I thought about it for
three days before I answered I wanted to
answer it as a Ralphie Perez Ralphie's
brother would answer it I didn't want to
answer it as Joey Diaz for the answer
sir what do you can't know I wish to
luck I told that I was her that this was
not I told her the truth this is not
your town if you haven't figured that
out you're on your own
shame on you shame on you right now in
the state of this town you are you know
I knew when he died that anybody and he
her blindness is so obvious that anybody
would know it the party was over parties
oh well let me take this house [ __ ]
dump this while the markets still high
make a future for my children this is
not bad advice take that house in
Nashville put that on the [ __ ] market
go down to Florida close to your
grandparents exactly I told and work the
ships with a [ __ ] the suitcase of
money in your backpack hmm never mind
Ralphie don't bring Ralph you up anymore
go for Lamas identity mm-hmm you know
look at the club schedules before you
read this article and make your judgment
look at any club schedule I'll send you
finals of you could find them she's not
told clubs nobody's hiring except
flappers even the ice house I've heard
through confidential Informer that the
ice house that they weren't gonna hire
anymore because she was doing Ralph's
bashing songs and that bothered the
management it bothered the management of
the [ __ ] ice house that she was still
up there
two years later singing a Ralphie Bashaw
which breaks my [ __ ] heart
what are you bashing yeah you're in a
[ __ ] house in the Hollywood Hills
because I am because of him you drive a
[ __ ] lame Range Rover today because
of him not because he on your merit or
cuz you did [ __ ] Big Mike's [ __ ]
rooms on those day nights at some
[ __ ] bar that's all from his [ __ ]
sweat that's not like Billy Goat [ __ ]
milk never smells like feet please
Mexico we lived in Salina we smelt all
kinds of [ __ ] on you snow leaves nekton
you go this is nothing compared to
robberies bug clean it was clear it
should be a spray trade on your neck
that's his call all the rage yeah
there's a prefabricated [ __ ] with this
[ __ ] no but that's the thing that really
like I said I woke up what and it's
funny cuz it happened on a Saturday yeah
usually called me and sadly I woke up
the last time and I [ __ ] waked up you
know 8:30 to a [ __ ] email from a
writer yeah telling me my [ __ ]
business yeah like telling me my
business there's a lot I don't know
about Bill birth past ya know about
Sebastian Maniscalco past yeah I don't
know much about [ __ ] Anthony Jeselnik
spaz so Haley Wong's past mm-hmm but if
there's somebody I knew for 20 [ __ ]
years its Ralphie May yeah I knew his
moods is you know I studied him yeah I
studied him don't [ __ ] come to me
with a Ralphie main story I'm putting it
on the table
yeah he was no angel we aggressive
towards the last year but try living
without your kids try having people
accusing you of things and yes some of
the allegations were true yeah he must
have passed out a few times with my
heads around we agree with that and we
agree with that 100% well he was not a
monster he's being created in his film
no I like a voucher 150 percent and for
some years you know my word is gold when
I come to this yeah he was a man with
false guess what I got fault
I don't always got full chance that
caught this [ __ ] guy here for his
Johnny faults you know wolf we all have
faults
percent but you have to it and he knew
them Rafi knew he had faults yeah
towards the end he didn't know he didn't
see you
he didn't see him I saw it that night
when he fell through the [ __ ] the
dollhouse dollhouse that he was the bags
under his eyes had troubled yeah you
know I was hearing the conflicting
reports from all over the country I've
been following this lead yep [ __ ]
stay yeah we've seen it firsthand
you know the Chiba Jews were going
strong once they sponsored that in like
twenty fifteen or fourteen and yeah but
melee 820 Chiba juice and leave fell
asleep after I left and I would fall
asleep after I ate a garbage can sure
filled with food which would be 2:00 in
the morning yeah I just wouldn't fall
asleep yeah I think if the seven years
we did the podcast I did fall asleep on
the podcast one day yeah yeah my dad's
yeah yeah well I'm sorry twice you're
right he was moaning
his name thank you for correcting me for
one night it just was I couldn't do it
no more yeah I just said keep doing what
you're doing
sure and the room was spinning right and
uh one night Steve fool yeah that we had
rerecord the podcast [ __ ] like I was
snoring and everything like the whole
[ __ ] thing yeah I get was just but
yeah just please ladies and gentlemen if
you I don't know what magazine it is I
like again I'm not here to put him down
yeah I want to put the writer down or do
you belong it down we just hit a tell
you the truth that this kid was Asus it
really was a city was we had some good
times on his birthday
yep one birthday we went to he came I
was no pass so I just wrapped up hey
Bart reads remember we decided Bart's he
came with Jodie fertig and me and Noah
Gonzales I don't know who else was there
we went to eat some shitty or two
Cracker Barrel oh okay
[ __ ] disgusting yeah yeah he loved he
loved it yeah right and Waffle House
he'd [ __ ] get a hard-on over a lawful
house at [ __ ] 3:30 in the mall that
place is disgusting
yeah and I remember another birthday we
celebrated in Jersey and he came and we
gave Tubbs a [ __ ] rice
drove up cuz that's at that time Alana's
in-laws lived in jerseys I'm talking
about mm Wow
yeah 99 maybe 2001 late because hash
waves were still open and he had started
a relationship with them on his own that
was a big belly in my hometown right he
had so once by the time he hit Last
Comic Standing he was just calling up
ash ways stop him by there and never
give him a tray a rice pudding and two
containers of whipped cream to go and
Ralphy would tell me I ate the whole
[ __ ] thing oh you know he did the
whole farm and broccoli one of those
trays great man yeah right now I can eat
the whole [ __ ] tray yeah but yeah
people that are listening to me we're
not trying to bash on Lana
I just just know that Ralphie was a good
person a real good man and a hilarious
comedian and we don't want his legacy to
be drug on and through the mud you know
what I mean like we love Ralph and and
he was a really really good guy you know
so any negative [ __ ] you hear out there
take it for what it is but he was a good
old boy that's what he used to say if
Ralphie liked you he would say he's a
good old boy and weed me my brothers
still say that to this day if you're a
good person you were a good old boy son
ralph was a good man you know he loved
you guys yeah I really appreciate you
two guys still holding him like a god it
really means the world to me because it
means that you know we live in Hollywood
man mm-hmm
and in Hollywood these are friends that
are Fairweather friends they're there
when the coke rocks a fly and the
pussy's flying they got your back once
that coke mark disappears you know that
gun there's most people like that but
with comedy when you're on your way up
everybody wants to be a friend I mean
you know Ralphie had requests
Ralphie used to show me [ __ ] that people
would send them that would blow your
mind and now I get those st. I'm sure
people enjoy what the [ __ ] do you are
you crazy you [ __ ] yeah it was just
weird to see his growth but I will tell
you one thing
and I told some of that he was a lot
better poor yeah he was a lot happier he
was so happy when he was four he would
sit in that [ __ ] one-bedroom apartment
and do his gigs and he had a look at you
know he had that for one that was
driving tipped over like the shot on the
left side he had I'm lying to you live
shocks would give them how it was like
that shirt you used to wear that button
that was holding on for dear life little
button it was over here merely with dial
after this before but would be holding I
thought I'd sharing and try to keep it
together
he destroyed those shock absorbers and
he's a floor runner ah a red and tan
4runner Lee you would see it come down
the block you can see that he break his
balls but was caught on with the shock
of the you're tipping over the seat was
[ __ ] up the seat you know you Cygnus a
seat and if you drop your car falling
under that you get sticky handles man
yeah in his car seat he had broken
everything it was just a seat that was
hot he had a drive like a yellow pages
that's how big it was that's how big he
was he had like renewing your four and
you go to the dentist or the haircut
they put like yellow pages down that was
heading towards the end he had flat not
the seat yeah the metal just went
through that'll just gave up that see
you can't believe these things but and
then when you call them out it
his face would get red yeah you [ __ ] you
a thousand yeah Toyota had [ __ ] up I
remember having this conversation
I still remember him and John Wesley
picking me up on a Monday at four
o'clock coming in from Miami no dough
you know yeah I heard you the show yeah
I snorted it I was into them for 200 for
the next time I went basher like the
next time I go back up only in four had
already dipped into to yeah and I'll
never forget him and John picking me up
and let's driving down with Sienna Gallo
I didn't want put a bumper I mean look
around go what happened you you became a
[ __ ] overnight like the chair yeah and
he's like I don't know what happened the
middle you don't know what happened I
say
800 pound even no I'm not I'm 462 it is
always with me you 462 what she'll even
says for 560 to show it to me right now
yeah unless you went to rouse really
lose his mind
what do you mean why would they wave me
around that's the cow oh we would
torment them that's when he was still
bald a jack-in-the-box oh yeah that was
this [ __ ] oh yeah you can leave the
store 15 minutes before Ralphie I'd
still get the Schrader's before him yeah
and go round for you what happened ah a
bomb I hit him on the street as soon as
you open this car door you got a whiff
you can see the jalapeno force the [ __ ]
off I'm rappers not the top of the
chicken sandwich and the
jalapeno-stuffed ah my god he would have
the cream cheese on his face telling you
only three of them yeah and then you
would say them come on it was likely I
mean gee three boxes alright 812
nobody would wait on that line he loved
he [ __ ] loved those things yeah most
disgusting things yeah I need the
jalapeno poppers but I know that they're
gonna enjoy di told me to put a jalapeno
popper up my [ __ ]
respect serve them to the public when
you eat that when you ate that Big Mac
what the [ __ ] do you think is on there I
don't know it's a [ __ ] some Arab guys
sweatin yeah Turk top 20 times no it
hasn't washed his hands in a month
no one goes to that thing thinking
you're going to stout burger like that's
a lie I knew Ralphie the least out of
all four of us but it like the stuff he
went through at the end was bad but
there's no one gets to be how big he got
happy like the really and I don't I
don't know and I don't know if we want
to talk about him or whatever but to get
that big like you know you eat you don't
go he he could have had a chef make him
jalapeno poppers it's not it's just as
uh there's something about that food
that gives you a little bit of happiness
real quick is it's it's to me it sounds
like it like at the end it was just the
accumulation of everything [ __ ] you up
a couple weeks ago we lost Kobe Bryant
right in that morning I landed at 9:30
from Atlanta
I saw the clouds in the fog and I got in
the car with Steve Simone I was in
terminal 4 got my American luggage I
shot up and to make a long story short I
wanted to you know I'm do I know Kobe
Bryant know that I have a meet Kobe
Bryant no was our fan yeah was I had a
super fan I'm a Julius Erving guy but I
was a fan that called me Bryant no damn
[ __ ] can play some ball rest and
peace know they have a mind works okay I
went to CBS and I just found this out of
57 guys okay so let me just tell you how
the mind works
I live whatever I think I tell people
CBS but I really went to the other one
right eight all right I went to right
eight the Rite Aid is my low point one
point one miles from my house that's how
I found that I looked at my wife then
the prescriptions
Ryan ate so I had to go to riding in a
prescription when I walked and I saw the
three woman crying my on the counter
I don't know copy but death when
somebody dies it triggers it triggers
yeah now I could write - that you guys
you know I get high I try to eat
a petabyte I try to eat a couple of
apples if I get a high at night and then
come on bananas like to that banana for
lunch you know just to help out I'm a
fat [ __ ] I don't want to die from a
heart attack whatever but let me tell
pain works Rob that's a good question
you brought up but I love you
you don't say much look at the man in
black it was like Johnny Cash did
[ __ ] they could even put you out of
the stage at that Folsom Prison yeah you
have to do from a jail cell finally but
I walked into their solos let me cry I
don't know him the pain is so deep
because when I walked in they were
having a sale and I totally this they
were having a sale on two for $5 Oreo
doubles oh come on yeah you know let's
be honest there's nothing like I know
it's like there's something like today
this how fat [ __ ] I am now if you buy a
pack of totally the tiger yeah a fox if
like school sports don't go out of
business
yeah and when I saw a commercial for two
minutes the fat [ __ ] was like maybe I'll
go buy ten boxes and I know that they
ain't gonna give a dime to kids totally
attack I don't give two [ __ ] about
Michel I was gonna give him five times
hundred thousand even though they sell
5,000 bucks yeah right but in my mind
the fat [ __ ] me but anyway getting
back for that day I was gonna buy those
Oreos just because of the pain it
brought up right and I caught myself I
go look yeah look how pain works oh my
god yeah I'm hungry but I don't want a
cheeseburger I don't want nothing
healthy I would eat those two bags
Laurie oh I'm suppressing pain for sure
so you're absolutely right his pain stem
that all the way to childhood big time
okay his day his pain stand back a
little with a childhood that were made
that's what made him the dangerous
comedy stand-up that he was yeah there
has to be pain mixed with in that feel
yeah in that material in that [ __ ]
jumbo that way to become comedians and
that 45 minutes there's pain in there
that's as simple all the guys whether
it's Bill burr you see he's happy he's
happy because he's making any 2 million
but what drives bill burr to be that
funny something he saw as a kid sure you
know bill work hard bill worked really
hard you know Sebastian
something he saw as a kid something
happened some trigger Allie want yeah
you know she saw some guy get hit with a
[ __ ] new Chuck which is why we gotta
stop this [ __ ] you know Whitney Cummings
all these people are the comedian's you
yeah me Lee all of us saw something
triggered something you know but that's
our natural reaction to eat a [ __ ]
bomb two boxes yeah
if you don't let me I would have taken
those home I'll even like milk I still I
hate milk yeah what an office not really
I hate how much more because it brings
terrorism you ever seen a cowboy herself
up in the name AHA what the [ __ ] you
know what I did my Oreos have known yeah
I could do a box of those easy right you
know many times I told myself do one
rope a couple rolls are going down a
couple roads are going down but that's
what pain is sure pain that comes to you
animation uh do a pill makes you either
eat 16 cheeseburgers in my case it was
the cocaine and then the sixteen
cheeseburgers yeah I didn't get to be
418 cuz I was the Pied Piper I didn't
see my dad lost a daughter
I lost a mother who I grieves or I lost
friends who I grieved I was angry and
frustrated about my life you know I'll I
end up on [ __ ] Selma Boulevard living
a block from Hollywood $700 a month
apartment with nine cats
you know meanwhile Ralphie's making
millions and I'm living I wasn't
apprehensive I wasn't angry around
because he could he would've gave me
those millions if I don't want it yeah
it wasn't that I was 418 pounds yeah I'm
at The Comedy Store Montreal don't want
me I see em don't watch it nobody wants
you Joe
getting around we think you're funny
well good does that do yeah that's it -
people thought I was funny I'm Mitzi
shore right yeah
so those three people kept me alive you
don't say so but in that meantime Josh
wolf is getting deals this guy is doing
this what am i doing I'm [ __ ] eat I'm
in pain man yeah I can't see my daughter
I got three pair of pants you know I'm
hooked on a [ __ ] drug that's horrible
yeah just horrible I wanted to get off I
didn't know where to [ __ ] this start I
didn't I didn't have 10,000 I go to
Malibu
sure rehab and I didn't want to go
because I know they weren't gonna help
what I had going right they weren't
gonna take away what I had that's
[ __ ] right a rehab is just a pit
stop to check everything and then
eventually you go back to your old
habits why I just put fine one beer on
we got Ralphie fresh out of rehab and
that was the worst we ever seen him well
when he first came out yeah we were the
first weekend he came out of rehab yeah
he came out like a [ __ ] rocket we get
on the bus he's all boys fresh out of
rehab he's all start rolling joints it
was his first day out there you go start
rolling joints and there was a [ __ ]
mound of and he had a roller and all the
supplies he gonna start rolling we're
gonna smoke till we get to Ohio and we
were like in Chicago yeah where
Schaumburg yeah do you remember when
they they tried to do an intervention
and he ran away yeah yeah
that [ __ ] never took more than
ten steps you know it he ran around and
then I heard he got on one of those
portable scooters yeah one of those
black guys you listen you're taking a
rap player like 2000 hours and they were
off and running
they threw me off the shuttle it was
just Ralphie [ __ ] a lot of chase them
come back he looked at them dog yeah
he's like [ __ ] you you know what you
people got stuff they didn't say that
yeah he just ran you got started running
like oh Jake jumping through [ __ ]
but the thing is yeah and he was hurling
[ __ ] luggage I rehab what are you
[ __ ] nuts vicodins in my pocket I'm
thinking about a hotel room right close
in here it is and they hadn't even had
that bleats yet oh yeah oh thank God he
would have been platinum you know it was
he was black no more right and nobody
you ordered like he did you know Jody
Arab would've delivered right this door
every [ __ ] time
yeah like here's your [ __ ] garlic
naan and here's your [ __ ] naan and
your chicken tender you guys got a paw a
little show on Wednesday land yeah where
the dirty show at the on Tara I'm
problem you know next month I'll be 14
years we've been doing that show 14
years the dirty show still can't get a
weekend can't get sucked in you yeah and
can't get a weekend out to give you a
story nobody has a story yeah we're not
YouTube these [ __ ] but yeah we got the
dirty show and then we're just and then
this weekend we're with Brad Williams
and then we're at Oxnard at levity life
I think after that okay yeah but where
are you a brand at the spotlight Casino
in India no [ __ ] yeah so we're gonna go
out there this weekend with him and
raise a little hell and and just have
fun we haven't worked with him in a good
five six months so we're excited to see
him I know Ralph he's looking down right
now very proud of you guys sleep assured
that and I guarantees in shock that all
the people that he helped out you two
guys are the only ones that are holding
up the [ __ ] Flag we're all forever
we Louie low how do you know the [ __ ]
you know that I just want people to know
that there's an article that's gonna
come out and you got three guys here to
have no reason a lot of you yeah three
people that don't drop it off for him
nope we don't do anything all we want
you know I put away a little something
for his kids
that's Kim yeah at some time when
they're ready I'll get it to the kids I
don't want the mom involved I don't want
a hands on it you know I'm sure that the
kid's gonna reach out he wants to know
I'm sure that we're gonna each get a
call yeah I pray that someday that his
daughter reach out
we want to know what happened that's the
obvious they all reach out yeah the soul
that's always the obvious and again I
won't say anything about the drugs yeah
because at the end it doesn't really
matter
nah you know it doesn't really matter
his contribution to comedy was huge what
he did for comedians
lots of wasum lots of them which was
just a humanitarian thing any any good
comic knows that you have to help the
younger guys sure what am I talking
about help putting it on the road or
whatever that's not help
guiding you yeah telling you little
things from time to time throwing you a
ball call that guy he's got a gig yeah
yes Annelle it's in Hell at seven and a
half hours on roller skate yep you can't
drive because the road is too thin right
gonna phase 800 and the [ __ ] food
yeah it'll suck your dick yeah and the
weight just got big titties massive blow
and you're like [ __ ] it I'll do it
that's what you know and that's what
people get confused with that that bet
you have to get the young guys and
nobody you know I've heard like I said
I've heard uh thousands of stories from
club owners both negative always with a
positive venture because they love them
but at the end he went out there to make
money for you yeah
ralphie took pride and making money for
you he did Ralph he really wanted the
waitstaff to make money I learned that
from Ralphie you know it's like when
people you know while we want this
beside would you do that and take that
percentage no don't do that to let them
get that taste also even though I know
they're robbing me mm-hmm
cuz they're all robbed a little bit come
on you know that anybody who's paying
cash that shit's fallen off the register
to register but you know you uh I
learned a lot in that man that we did I
learned a lot in that man I've learned
how to be a gentleman and that's why I
can't believe out of all the things
Ralph he was one thing they forget in
this whole article is to say that he's a
gentleman
you know you could say all this [ __ ]
wanna tells you you can make all the
assessments from the documentary or the
memoir I'm telling you one thing
straight up then he was a gentleman and
at the end of the day that's more
important than being a millionaire
that's more important than being a movie
star that's the most important thing and
that's what I took from him that's why I
act the way I do because he was a
gentleman man and yeah he left us with
that and I hope he's having a good time
up there with bro he's probably go from
Brody no I said Brody let me teach how
to tie a knot you know is ralph was a
good guy and that's that's the only
thing that you know we want to make sure
it's clear but he was a good he was a
good good guy you know so and he wasn't
that you know all tortured soul he had
good and bad times but he was a good guy
and that's what good time in the 20
years I know they're all good than bad
there was 12 great years and eight ones
where it was shady and that's all of us
yeah if that's what percent of your life
but he wasn't an abuser no no he wasn't
whatever the pain led him to the [ __ ]
pills he get all those yeah days on
those pills are the easier addict oh
yeah listen but my [ __ ] I gotta go
starting it got approved I got hit on
Friday I didn't know it I got it on my
insurance pays like my doctor pays
I gotta start going I'm not doing it
next Monday cuz they're doing the Kobe
Bryant thing and you do not want to get
in your car next 100 if you live in the
LA area if you go on to the Kobe thing
yeah I heard they don't even want people
going down there which means come down
don't say that yeah don't say we don't
want people to come down here because
now they gotta come down everyone's come
so next Monday the 24th the 101 is gonna
be a [ __ ] owl in the morning and a
redline there's gonna be even [ __ ]
worse and I can't imagine the 405 so
whatever plans you may have
I stay at home watch the tribute at all
yep put your Laker shirt on I'm saying
prayer because it's gonna be [ __ ]
crazy
oh yeah I can't even imagine I know for
a fact I read that every hotel around
downtown is already a hundred percent
book wow that means people are flying in
for this Kobe memorial which I don't he
was a great basketball player loved to
death but uh it's gonna be [ __ ] crazy
next Monday long in town so I don't want
to do not fine so after that I gotta
start going for a shots mmm I gotta take
three shots three Mondays in a row well
on my knee
epidural injections no they're not
epidural these are gel you put a coating
in between the bones I'll try this in to
numb the arthritis a little bit I can't
imagine the pain he was walking it oh
yeah someone you laid out of bed and you
get up if you're in that bed for six
[ __ ] hours and you get up your legs
you know yeah your legs is [ __ ] yeah
eggs a [ __ ] you gotta walk you got to do
certain things you know and when you
when you lay down and then you get up
and walk and you're heavy as we are I am
totally aren't you [ __ ] it hurts no
no you know those walk through airports
there's a [ __ ] saw yesterday in
Phoenix it was tremendous I made the
walk there was a little black do sit
there like this I peeled off a toilet
door and see you know I can see 19 the
last one yeah yeah at the sky Sky Harbor
[ __ ] you I said you busy goes no I go
history of us I gave him a 20 right to
the front there was a little old lady
next to us you think I like this man I
don't forget the tip the same Dunham
[ __ ] white you know a look lift a rock
Elena made her security guard
you wouldn't want to walk this would you
give him a [ __ ] dead yeah I looked at
me and these white [ __ ] it's
cheaper I know you gotta check him at
the airport your regular diet x5d
world's black guys are right at 20 in
Dallas I had a guy I was doing 90 one
time he was running over people
yeah well it's good to see that you're
still doing your thing graduations on
the 14 years thank you
if I get an impulse maybe I'll Drive
come back I real but the chances are
slim yeah we know that's okay got the
[ __ ] you've done it before though oh
yeah yeah it was tremendous yeah you
guys the update giving away Bilbo's yeah
yeah women OH leaving angry oh yeah
we've seen uh [ __ ] mixing their
drinks up with 12-inch [ __ ] dildos
you still get sponsored by the yeah yeah
we used to get glass ones believe it or
not like the same guy that make pipes
would make us these dildos that you can
put in your [ __ ] dishwasher but we
were flying around with them through TSA
and we had this special suitcase made
and we would always play rock scissors
paper who's gonna carry the glass dildos
is carry on because they would always
pull you over and then put on their
gloves and grab your dildos and ask you
a million questions so Chad's a cheap
[ __ ]
I would always lose and I was always
getting caught through TSA but you know
25 glass dildos going through the ringer
in TSA so we better get in filming
they'll be hysterical that we quit doing
it we don't even bring them on the road
no more because they pull us over in TSA
every time and TSA now and you get
pulled over into that back room I mean
you're stripping down you're getting
naked you point up your nutsack
really yeah they've stripped us down
made us one time we were with Ralphie
and they go have you handled explosives
today and I was just kidding I go just
my dick and I swear to god they pulled
me and Ralphie to the side and made us
get into our underwears because I joked
about having an explosive in my pants in
a Detroit Airport I was talking [ __ ] I'm
all you should search him they probably
got drugs and all kinds of [ __ ] on him I
was just talking on they made us strip
down Ralphie had to lift up his titties
the whole team yeah he was so mad at me
most of them 20ms opposed holy [ __ ] how
to help him with his belt the whole look
at that leg yeah about that and he's
always go
[Laughter]
now you put on one shoe and that's 20
minutes at least
come here you [ __ ] get like a spool
but that's a major level yeah I'm happy
[ __ ] how could people find you
a Cory and Chad on our smash brothers on
any Instagram Cory and Chad cor YNC HTML
webpage yeah we got identical
entertainments yeah what's it called
identical entertainment yeah that's
artifice yeah the guys are [ __ ]
brothers man we appreciate it
I appreciate you celebrate Ralphie's
would do a couple bong hits now yeah me
and we're gonna do another Heather book
yeah you say he's going to the sushi Oh
is he he's gonna sushi damn happy hour
Oh 22 tuna rolls he don't give a [ __ ] I
don't win he won't eat [ __ ] yeah he
started he started asking what the
George Perez ISM took a quart a chick
that ass cork and put in his mouth he's
trying to talk to you Indian ass let me
tell you what happened he sucked on the
court juice oh yeah aside from eating
dirty yeah but you got to put him in a
Jacuzzi first that's Matt's mom oh no he
got the pink guy in the jacuzzi already
he's gotta build his music yeah the pig
eating the [ __ ] pig yeah you know
what's in that big yeah you don't know
you eat ass on the wrong day you'll go
out like Val Kilmer and tombstone it was
in her but it was in our but I was on
the stage okay yeah
no tasting this [ __ ] she was I don't
think she said this year you might as
well take that you guys were thinking
that a month I'm too hard to drive to
McDonald right now tomorrow
they kick that yeah take your dad down
all these will be 67 I don't want yeah I
don't want to take my dad to extrapolate
oh for sure yeah we'll take I have a
half a valium yeah and where the Bulls
will just leave me down I'm gonna go get
George Perez to give them a room I pay
for a hotel down the corner you can come
home like that yeah easy breezy that's
it your dad will be in there getting I
don't want anyone added to the will you
no one's giving my dad I'm [ __ ] blue
pill whatever that will get him one of
those gas station dick pills black rhino
dick and chip concrete Brian Redman
Thomas a red band told me about him and
then I love you take the gas station
cells dick pills they're called like a
black rhino 7,000 your [ __ ] dicks
hard for seven days no [ __ ] I
thought Chad was gonna have a heart
attack like John Candy this [ __ ] guy
he was I walked in on him he was [ __ ]
away leak that's a good thing about twin
brother oh just some waitress at some
comedy club and I just pounding away on
her and he walked in on me and I was
[ __ ] doing the Lord's work I mean I'm
telling you dick and closer than I would
be oh we're twins it's okay same thing
you and your dad will be you'll be
pushing on your dad's ass he's bottoming
out on the breakfast issue right down to
George Perez yeah yeah yeah just drop
more yeah give him everything
oh yeah I breakfast when he's on the
viagra powder with his eggs yeah [ __ ]
we'll both do heavy duty yeah give him
like a gallon a Pedialyte on the way
down that way he's nice and hydrated in
your life yeah cuz he's gonna come a lot
oh Jesus come on disgusting look at a
guy are you yeah don't be a piece of
[ __ ] no
do whatever you want sirs birthday I go
yeah what would you want in your 67th
birthday a scarf a watch or a yarmulke
yeah no you want some of your puppy [ __ ]
yeah balls to be open at your father
that's your father
yeah come on
yep so family no that's a family thing
yeah no sale word big here yeah here's
quiet the whole at home will be nice
when we family celebrate by taking their
old man out and getting soft on me my
father was alive he my brother my dad
[Laughter]
yeah do some chick 200 some runaway them
take them over on Laker sham right over
there that [ __ ] [ __ ] garbage reps
that run away yeah no big deal no she'll
make a movie so Friday you'll get on the
floor and brag about yeah yeah I'd be
like my son got me sucked off that's
what he's gonna tell people he got me a
[ __ ] nut juice is dink looking like
cottage cheese shooting out of his car
cause she's last night Oh see then
you're thinking it up is his load for
the agent so you get him some pineapple
juice that way he's dropping good loads
on him
Oh anyway this podcast is brought to you
by zip recruiter why because I know
hiring it's challenging okay when
codable co-founder Gretchen had the
experience how challenging hiring could
be emphasized unsuccessfully searching
for a new game artists to grow her
education company she switched the zip
recruiter and saw the immediate
difference and you
to sign up for free right now today
zipper kulit calm slash Church zip
recruiter doesn't depend on candidates
finding you it finds them for you and by
using the zip recruiter screening
questions to filter candidates
Gretchen found it easier to focus on the
best ones then she found the route one
in fact after posting her job on the zip
recruiter Gretchen said she was honestly
surprised she found the qualified
applicant so quickly and hired a new
game artist in less than two weeks who's
better than that nobody so do me a favor
right now results like that it's no
wonder four out of five employers who
post on zip recruiter get a quality
candidate before it within the first day
one day do me a favor whether you're big
or small we don't care
zip recruiter is effective with
businesses of all sizes try zip
recruiter for free at exclusive ready
grab a pen Capital Z zip recruiter comm
slash Church again that's zip recruiter
comm slash shirts zip recruiter the
smartest way to hire I don't forget I'm
gonna be in Las Vegas at Treasure Island
February 28th and then I got nothing
till the Arlington thena in Santa
Barbara on March 27th I got [ __ ] to do
and people to see so if you don't see me
in Las Vegas you have to wait and see me
in Santa Barbara or come to the [ __ ]
Comedy Store [ __ ] I don't know
what the Tabas ID that I love you guys a
little Cory and Chad I want to tell my
brother up in heaven happy birthday
we're still thinking about him we
haven't forgotten about it and I want to
thank Christ killer for being here this
[ __ ] Butte and that's it I have a
great Tuesday and I'll see you
[ __ ] Thursday tip-top
[ __ ] Magoo stay black I love
you